[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
he's a caged animal
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
is wrong with this fool
and he also he also doxed he also doxed
his attorneys which is
hell right on brand for this [__] isn't
it
yes that's right he docks his attorneys
there's a cell phone number on the
letter that Donald Trump posted on true
social now if you're not aware
Donald Trump forced his attorneys it
seems it seems because it really feels
like he wrote it I'm actually gonna call
the attorneys today I think
uh me and Gabe Sanchez are going to call
the attorneys I want to ask him a
question
I don't know
I want to ask him a question we'll see
if the number still works I want to ask
him
did you write the letter or did he write
the letter who wrote the [__] letter
because they're begging Merrick Garland
to do a mulligan on this one
that's what they're doing
absolutely begging him
did you see the letter did you see I'm
gonna show it to you
you really don't need to see it it's
it's exactly what you think it is he's
begging please please don't indict me
please please please don't let Jack
Smith keep investigating oh no you found
you found foreign transactions that are
[__] illegal and probably borderline
on treason if I sold classified
documents that I stole from the
government
you know what's crazy about all this
the thought right like
if if
what we think
the obvious is true that he stole
documents and he sold them right
because that's that's the thing here
that's the that is the Crux of the aim
of Jack Smith is the documents case
yeah he's doing January 6th the coup
the overthrowing of the government
but when you sell classified documents
to foreign governments for money that's
[__] Espionage that's [__] treason
why else why else
would they subpoena his [__] business
records
with foreign governments
in the documents case what could it
possibly [__] be
come on man
are we we're not this stupid are we
think about it
it's not that hard yes the most obvious
thing is probably the most true
it's obvious Trump is a dirt bag it's
obvious he's desperate for money
he's broke
it's obvious he stole documents it's
obvious he tried to hide that he stole
documents and he's still doing that
and he's lying about it
so yeah he probably sold the
[__]
it's a it's a damn good possibility
that he traded away our secrets for his
money
which is [__] espionage
what else how else do you want me to say
it but the craziest part the craziest
part about it is we're gonna watch Ron
DeSantis absolutely [__] Crash and
Burn
on Twitter
apparently uh Rhonda Santos is going to
announce
that he's gonna launch his campaign for
president United States I don't know if
he's gonna resign as Governor I don't
think they passed that law have they
passed that law I don't think they pass
a law I think he has to actually resign
to run for president I mean maybe he'll
go to court but I mean it's a
possibility that Ron DeSantis will run
for president he'll Crash and Burn and
he won't be governor in Florida anymore
you can't get that [__] on
Twitter spaces fast enough
if that's the case fine [__] them
listen I I know a lot of people are
really hyped up about the santis getting
in the race all 12 of you
literally there's like 12 maybe 13
people that are excited about this
let me tell you as soon as we're on this
antisenders the race
Trump is absolutely going to destroy him
going to [__] dismantle him top to
bottom Ronda santis will no longer ever
in the history of ever ever enter
politics ever again
that's it he's going to destroy him
this is gonna be another [__] Scott
Walker moment
in Republican governorism
where oh man DeSantis he's so great oh
Scott Walker he's so great
Crash and Burn
and the best part is he's gonna do it
live on Twitter spaces with Elon Musk
one of the best rake steppers there is
now again people there's 12 13 maybe it
could possibly be 14 or 15 people that
are excited about Ron DeSantis
announcing
there's a lot of people excited about
the possibility of him announcing
tonight on Twitter
I mean he could change his mind I don't
know
it's a possibility he's a coward so it
would likely
be that he could change his mind
but I don't know I don't know if they I
don't I I literally do not know if they
pass that law in Florida did they
I'm not in Florida I don't keep up with
the Florida Republicans
and what they're doing to save or not
save their fascist leader
but it seems to be that the Republicans
in Florida don't want Ron DeSantis to
run
I don't know
I don't I don't I don't think they
passed it
someone some some are saying yes some
are saying no it's unclear at this point
oh they did pass okay and they did pass
all right all right that's good that's
good that's good on Ronnie that way he
can remain the Florida fascist
and run for president see this is the
problem that he's going to have though
really honestly with Trump
the problem he's gonna have is he's
gonna not be being governor and every
single time Trump is going to bury him
on it
right
and if Chris Christie gets in this race
Chris Christie is going to do the same
thing
Tim Scott he's gone Nikki Haley she's
out
Assa Hutchinson that [__] isn't
it's done
okay
so Ronda Santos is the only one that
even has a shot and after tonight it'll
be clear that he doesn't have a chance
in hell
my guess is a lot of people are
speculating that Donald Trump is going
to start tweeting the moment that Rhonda
Santa's voice comes on Twitter
which would be fantastic everyone
doesn't want Trump on Twitter but let me
tell you something
tonight
Ron DeSantis the moment he opens his
mouth Donald Trump just starts tweeting
like just rage tweeting can you imagine
that on Twitter because he's got his
account Elon gave him his account I
actually think that's what elon's doing
here
Elon is is not propping up DeSantis
he's baiting Trump
he's baiting Trump to [__] come tweet
is what he's doing
because I I actually think that that's
what elon's plan is here
and you know it's maybe one of the
smartest things that elon's ever done
maybe I you know [__] I don't know how
am I how am I supposed to know we won't
know until it happens these things have
never happened before
there's one thing I know
is that Rhonda santis is a weak little
[__]
he's a coward he's a [__] ass [__] way
more than the Cheeto does cueing on her
and Donald Trump is going to use a
flamethrower
against DeSantis
and it's not going to be pretty for
DeSantis and I'm all here for it I'm
excited about it
you should be too
we're gonna want someone who's supposed
to be the rising star in the Republican
Party
he's one of the young leaders of the
Republican party and they are gonna
absolutely [__] destroy him
let's do it baby let's do it and all the
while all the while Donald Trump's going
to be indicted on God knows what charges
God knows where DC Georgia who knows it
could be other places there could be
more charges coming in New York who
knows who the [__] knows and they're
still gonna make him the nominee
because they don't give a [__]
they don't care it's all about owning
Libs have you seen this target [__] of
course the left is really pissed off
because Target's taking down their
displays in their stores and the only
reason why they're taking down their
sways is because people are going in and
destroying those [__]
because they're [__] terrorist
they're [__] terrorists and they're
[__] Liars if you want to know the
truth there's a bunch of accounts on
Tick Tock that are absolutely lying
about the clothes that are in Target
and they're absolutely destroying the
display so yeah of course they're going
to take down the displays because
they're [__] they're destroying them
they're kicking them over and tearing
[__] off of them
these people are insane man they're
[__] insane they're they're outside
their [__] minds
and it's just a few and far between
folks this isn't this isn't a large
percentage of the population
it's a lot it's a large number of people
I'll get I'll give you that but it's not
a large percentage of the population
most people are like who gives a [__]
man I found this morning on Amazon when
I saw some of these videos
of these people whining and bitching
about Target having onesies to have
rainbows on them
and say Pride
I went to Amazon and looked up I just
here's what I typed in I I [__] I [__]
you not I wouldn't [__] you you're my
favorite turd I typed in on Amazon Mom
Dad baby clothes that's what I typed in
mom dad baby clothes that's what I
searched on Amazon
I'm one of the first ones that came up
said I love Mom and Dad nothing sexual
about it nothing inherently evil or
demonic
it's not indoctrination
it's just a baby onesie that says I love
Mom and Dad
you see them all the time
oh but my God if you put that heart as a
rainbow and put I love Mom and Mom oh my
God it's inherently sexual now you
[__] idiots out there that are
[__] transphobes and homophobes
you people are sick there's something
sick about you
there's something really [__] up in
your brain that you think because
there's a relationship between people
somehow it's inherently sexual
when that when that relationship
is out in the open what are you talking
about so you're telling me every time
every time you see a man and a woman
holding hands in in public that somehow
inherently sexual
if a man kisses his wife in public or a
wife kisses her husband in public that's
inherently sexual
if if if they acknowledge that they are
together a man and a woman are together
and they love each other and they're in
a relationship that's inherently sexual
you people are [__] weirdos you you
you concentrate way too much on
genitalia and you're way too hyper
focused on who's [__] who you're
weird it's [__] weird most people do
not run around
and their main thoughts are who's
[__] who
and how much are they [__]
you people are [__] you you need you
need to get some help and I know in this
country with Republicans running most of
this these states and blocking mental
health care I know it's difficult
to get mental health care
but you need to seek help somewhere
Jesus [__] Christ
just because just because people people
are in a homosexual relationship lgbtq
just because they're trans doesn't
inherently make them sexual you sick
[__]
Jesus [__] Christ
what's wrong with you [__]
and then lying about the children's
clothes oh there's tons of videos out
there they'll go they'll go into one
section an adult section of the store
and they'll grab an item and they go and
they bring it over to the kids and
they're showing tags and [__] and it's
not the actual kids clothes they're
lying [__] they're lying it's
all [__] lies and it's all to to stop
stochastic terrorism towards the lgbtq
community and someone's gonna get
[__] killed
you dumb sons of [__] someone is
gonna get [__] killed and that's and
and I know the left is mad I know the
left is mad about Target taking down
this place but honestly if I was a
manager at Target I wouldn't want those
[__] coming in there and doing
all kinds of crazy ass [__] in my store
yes yes do you need to stand up against
them sure certainly but Jesus [__]
Christ someone's gonna get hurt or
killed listen
this hate speech [__] needs to be
enforced now it needs to be enforced if
you're running around with [__]
weapons threatening people threatening
people go
Jail jail charges hate crime charges
it's enough of this stuff it's enough
it's not free speech to run around
threatening other [__] because
they're in a marginalized community that
you don't like you can hold the belief
that you don't like someone because of
their sexual orientation but you do not
get to [__] threaten them that it's
not a [__] thing
it's not your First Amendment right to
threaten somebody
it's enough of the [__] domestic
terrorism it's enough of the [__]
these are [__] Americans these are a
fellow human [__] beans yeah you may
not like who they are but that's a you
problem not a them problem [__]
we have Liberty we have rights we have
freedom in this [__] country and they
get to be and love who the [__] they
want regardless of how you feel about it
because it's a you problem that you have
with them so keep it to your [__]
self
don't be threatening people and honestly
honestly I can't believe that Target
isn't [__] getting some of these
these tick tockers and these social
media people on [__] line and banning
them from their stores ban those
[__] for Life get the [__] out
of those stores if you don't like if you
don't like Target and you don't like to
shop there then stay the [__] out of
their stores
you [__] hateful bigots
stay the [__] away from other human
beings you people are [__] sick
you Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro type
[__]
it's enough of the Nazi [__] it's enough
of it it's [__] enough of it and this
morning a a great account on Twitter
Merrick pointed out Matt Walsh the
[__] has gone from talking about
it's all about trans kids it's all about
trans kids and turning our kids into
trans children
now it's full on the lgbtq community
anything that has a [__] Rainbow on
it they're [__] terrified of and they
want to use domestic terrorism to get
rid of it
well [__] you
it's not for the [__]
and if you don't speak out and you don't
say something and again the left always
does this stupid [__] and I'm gonna call
you [__] out I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it you [__] are
are banging on target it's not Target
it's not Target it's not Target
it's not Target yes yes is their little
corporate pride thing maybe it's maybe
it's disingenuous fine whatever you can
have your opinion about that
but Target is not creating these
domestic terrorists
it's Matt Walsh it's the daily wire
it's Marjorie Taylor green
it's the white Christian nationalist
it's Rhonda santis it's Mike Parsons
these are the people it's these [__]
Republicans creating these domestic
terrorists not [__] Target aim your
anger where it belongs
stop doing stupid [__] with your [__]
outrage it's ridiculous and I'm talking
to the left
stop aiming your our outrage in the
wrong direction it doesn't work
it only it only it only empowers these
[__]
go after the [__] Nazis that's where
you go that's where your outrage is
so Puck your head out of your goddamn
ass and stop tweeting about Target
stop
stupid [__]
Target didn't cause this problem there
isn't a problem with selling a [__]
shirt with a goddamn Rainbow on it if
people want to buy it
you're not hurting anybody
it's the [__] right-wing Nazi
terrorist going into destroying these
displays because they [__] hate gay
people
so stop
being such [__] boneheads
and that's why you come here every day
because I'm gonna tell it to you [__]
straight
I'm gonna give you what
what everyone else is thinking
yeah they're gonna be people attack me
on Twitter I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] you can [__] attack me
all you want about me saying it's not
Target's problem it's not it's not
they're not the [__] problem yes yes
them being disingenuous about Pride sure
whatever fine but they're not [__]
trying to [__] kill people
you don't see target employees out there
with [__] semi-automatic weapons
threatening the lgbtq community you
don't see the [__] managers of target
with semi-automatic weapons going into
stores standing outside of stores and
threatening the lgbtq community you
don't see them tweet Target tweeting
then build [__] stochastic terrorist
threats towards the lgbtq community
there's a [__] difference
so use your [__] head
and point your outrage in the correct
direction
that's what you should do oh oh Target's
taking their displays down quit your
[__] crying
quit your [__] crying
buck up and aim your [__] outrage in
the correct direction
that's what you do
yes again I I get the whole Target thing
oh Target they're they're caving to the
right the [__] out of here
the [__] out of here maybe maybe what we
should do maybe what we should do is
defend the lgbtq community
and defend the [__] allies of the
lgbtq community
and maybe Target would go you know what
you're [__] right you're [__]
right [__] these [__]
I'm telling you
the only way we beat these [__]
is aim our outrage in the correct
direction folks
the only way we beat these sons of
[__] these [__] Nazis is our
narrative and our [__] story
a what the um what America is really
about
you either believe in Liberty and you
believe in freedom and rights or you
don't
and your outrage should be directed in
the correct direction to reflect at
every single [__] day
I'm telling you right now
the lgbtq community wants us to be
allies in the fight with them
against the people who are trying to
exterminate them
in our society with laws they're they're
passing legislation
to get rid of lgbtq people in their
states Jesus Christ [__] Rick Scott
puts out a statement this morning
senator from the state of Florida that
he wants Floridians to be hostile
hostile to socialists and Communists
whatever the [__] that means
it's terrorism
and you're mad at Target
the [__] out of here I almost bet you I
almost bet you a lot of [__] money
I'm not a betting guy with money but I
bet you a lot of [__] money that the
LGB GQ Community what they want is us to
stand with them
and aim our Direction at the people who
are trying to [__] exterminate them
and trying to get rid of them Society
not against [__] Target
as if Target makes a big [__]
difference what laws does Target write
what laws or Target it's Target writing
to get rid
of the rights of people in States huh
tell me show me show me the [__] laws
show me
I'm telling you you need to [__] get
your outrage in the correct direction
it's gonna be a hell of a [__] fight
it's going to be a hell of a [__]
fight
over the next 18 months
tonight's going to show it clearly
when Rhonda santis announces
and we must draw wedges between the
fascists we must get them to hurt each
other
we must get them to fight with each
other it is super important
so if you're mad at Target fine whatever
don't buy [__] at Target just like the
people who don't like the pride display
at Target you don't like Target don't
[__] shop there
don't don't shop there and I don't know
what you mean I just don't go there
but if you want change
if you want change then you're gonna
have to engage in your democracy
and you're gonna have to point your
strategic outrage in the correct
direction to make that change it that's
what's gonna have to happen
and by the way by the way what let them
think they had their success because
they're they're gonna flout it
now that you went online and you said
Target I can't believe you're doing this
target I can't believe you're doing this
I'm gonna boycott Target I'm gonna
boycott Target guess what
you're doing exactly what the right ones
holy [__] [__]
oh are you on their side I'm not saying
you're on their side
but you're doing exactly what they want
exactly
oh boy
maybe you'll be mad at me maybe you
won't and maybe you'll listen to me [__]
I don't know you listen to me every
single weekday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast new Nissan 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch do not
forget
do not forget
to subscribe here on YouTube also follow
us on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google if you're on Facebook
you can watch on Facebook I know several
people watch on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels you can watch us at the Tony
Michaels also you can follow us on
Twitch for free
it's free to follow us on Twitch
and boy have we gotten a lot of Support
over on Twitch
it's been amazing now if you want to
open up a Twitch account some people are
asking how to open up a Twitch account
you can just go to twitch.tv right here
it is twitch.tv and you can type in
slash D Tony Michaels you can open a
Twitch account now
once you have that Twitch account or if
you have a Twitch account if you have an
Amazon Prime account you can link your
Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account
and because here's the great thing if
you have a Prime account you get one
free subscription on Twitch for a
Creator or streamer whatever the hell
it's called over there I think they're
we're called streamers
I'm all kinds of things all kinds of
places
and twitch we're streamers you can give
your favorite streamer one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account which gives us a couple dollars
each month and boy have you guys came
through we got over 200 our next goal is
300 subscribers so if you got an Amazon
Prime account open a Twitch account link
your Prime account to your Twitch
account here's how you do it go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com the link to show you how it
directs you it takes like four seconds
to show you how to link your Amazon and
your Twitch account is right there on my
website you just go like four down it
says link Amazon and twitch you click
that it'll take you directly to Amazon
gaming it'll give you the exact
directions once you have a Twitch
account to link those and then you give
us that one free subscription every
single month and you have to renew it
every single month
so if you're out there and you've given
us that subscription you got to go in it
takes just as much time to renew it as
it did to connect it actually about half
like two seconds to renew the
subscription
so make sure that you go in and you
renew your subscription every single
month we appreciate all the support on
Twitch it's been exciting
um and I think we're gonna do more and
more over on Twitch because we're
getting more and more viewers more and
more followers over on Twitch the chat
is over there it's Lively it's getting
more and more lively
um big stuff and and CB they were
talking I think it was last week they're
like we were the only two over here for
a long time
so and and give a shout out to Robin
while you're over there as the moderator
on Twitch thank you Robin for moderating
on Twitch
hell boy we got a lot of [__] to get to
today and I'm sure there's going to be
more news I was listening to Kevin
McCarthy as I was coming into the show
he's blaming he's blaming Joe Biden
for not doing his job everyone stick
around we're going to talk about that
more when we come back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist feel full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babble mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
I got some crazy [__] to talk about
today
because Republicans exist I I you know
I'll tell you that you know
I love doing this show I love having you
guys here every single weekday two full
hours and I'd love to go to three you
know that you know I'd love to go to
three four full hours every single
weekday Monday through Friday at noon
Eastern three full hours and we're
getting there it's slow it's slow but
we're getting there we're getting there
I I would imagine by sometime next year
and when we get into the full-throated
uh
2024 cycle especially in the Republican
primaries
um As Trump just Slaughters these people
and we'll probably we'll probably it
will probably be feasible for us to do
three full hours but you you are the
backbone of this show
you are the absolute backbone of this
show but I will say without Republicans
without Republicans boy it would be hard
for us to create content here I mean it
would it would it would really be a
heavy lift to do three hours and keep
you guys entertained these [__]
just don't let up with the stupidity oh
my god did you see the [__] letter
did you see this letter
what the [__] I'm talking about the
letter with Trump
have you guys seen this thing
boy it's crazy [__] let me let me pull
it up here for you
um
I'll show you what it says here are you
ready okay here's here's um here's the
letter uh to America Garland okay you
see there the attorney general in the
United States
um it says
uh he totally wrote this [__] he
totally wrote this [__] now they
made a word Smith did a bit right to
make it sound like I don't know
to make it sound like a lawyer wrote
this
I'm guessing ah [__] how am I what am
how am I supposed to know really okay
here's
hell this stupid [__] here's what it
says Dear attorney general Garland
we represent Donald J Trump here's how
you know
that it was written by him the 45th
president of the United States
yeah everyone knows that that you
pretended to be the 45th president of
the United States yeah we get it it goes
on to say in the investigation currently
being conducted by the special counsel's
office leaves the name Jack Smith out
right he puts his name in puts his old
title the thing he pretend to use to do
like be the 45th president but he
doesn't even say Jack Smith's name
he goes on to say unlike President Biden
and his son Hunter and the Biden family
president Trump is being treated
unfairly okay let's break down this idea
all right so we know that Jim Comer and
the Q an honors Republicans in the house
tried to act like there was going to be
some sort of Investigation into Joe
Biden under binding his families for
foreign transactions okay you got that
that is something that happened none of
the [__] they're saying has anything to
do that they have elements of of crime
but they're saying well look here Hunter
Batten Biden crime family okay there's
that thing there right floating around
in space now
the other thing that we found out
yesterday is that Jack Smith subpoenaed
Donald Trump's foreign transactions and
payments from foreign governments like
turkey and Saudi Arabia and several
others from the Trump organization
which is really bad when a federal
prosecutor a special counsel who's in
doing a criminal investigation is
subpoenaing your your [__] payment
records so we have both these things
flying around in space right we're here
it's almost like one of them's real
it's almost like one of them is real
where a federal special counsel Jack
Smith has subpoenaed payments that
Donald Trump received from foreign
governments got are you following
in a criminal investigation and then
there's this [__] weird fake ass
thing over here where they have a couple
transactions that not Joe Biden received
from foreign payments and it's almost
like Grandpa here is equating the two
things are you seeing that do you see
the connection between a and b
I just want to point this out again let
me reiterate he says unlike and he says
because he [__] wrote this there is
no you couldn't pay attorneys enough
[__] money to write this [__]
unlike President Biden his son Hunter
and the Biden family president Trump is
being treated unfairly
the thing that's not true that's all
[__] that the Republicans are trying
to spend in the house at the direction
of the Cheeto deaths cue in honor okay
it's obvious the reason why they're
doing it is to distract from the actual
crimes
of the Chino dust cue in honor that's
all I'm saying that's all I'm saying and
he's begging mayor Garland here to get a
meeting it says it goes on to say no
president of the United States has ever
in the history of our country
been base
baselessly investigated in such an
outrageous and unlawful fashion which is
entirely none of that is true none of it
it's not baseless it's not outrageous
it's not unlawful
it's possible you committed crimes it's
possible that it's very obvious that you
committed crimes with material evidence
so you would be expected to pay the
price for the laws that you broke and
the felonies that you committed it's
kind of the thing here in the United
States
he goes on to say we request
begging is what he means we request a
meeting at your earliest convenience the
quicker the better because we know we're
in hot [__]
to discuss the ongoing Injustice that is
being perpetrated by your special
counsel and his prosecutors look Merrick
Garland is going to laugh at this
he's probably already [__] wanted
this thing up and threw it in trash got
it
and the reason why is because Merrick
Garland appointed the special counsel to
do this job
that's what he did and there is no sign
at all that Jack Smith is a dummy
now here's what I believe a lot of
people think that the the indictments
are going to come very fast
I don't actually think that
I don't think that they're coming
anytime really soon maybe sometime this
year
but I think I think Jack Smith is going
to do a little different than what
Robert Mueller did do you remember the
Mueller investigation where time and
time a little bit of time went by they
indicted a few a little bit more time
they indicted a few more they collected
this evidence indicted these people they
collect this evidence tonight of these
people I actually think Jack Smith is
not going to do that I actually think
Jack Smith is going to do everything
all at once he's gonna drop this entire
story this entire criminal investigation
all at once
that way no one can say oh well you're
just trying to affect the election no
this is the [__] crimes here's the
[__] charges here's the people who
are indicted here it is you can do it
what you want I'm just charged to
prosecute these people that's my [__]
job
I believe that is where
it is going to be now that just means
that it's going to prolong
this thing right it's just going to
prolong this process in our minds
because we want justice as fast as
possible Right but I actually don't
think that that is the I don't think
that that's the appropriate Justice here
the appropriate Justice is to hold them
all accountable all at once and just
drop the [__] just get it just [__]
drop it on them and the reason why is
because we watched what happened with
the Mueller investigation and we know
what the Trump chaos machine will do
each time there's here's this round of
charges here's this round of charges
here's this round of charges when that
happens what they what they will do is
they will they will make sure to attach
any kind of chaos that they absolutely
can to discredit everything if it's all
at once if it's all at once it will be
much harder for Trump and his chaos
machine to do that
and I believe Jack Smith is going to
take
the path of least resistance here which
is to make sure that not only he has all
the material evidence for each and every
single indictment that is
that is brought to bear
but that he does it swiftly when it
happens so
but it seems like um grandpa is a little
scared that um that
that Jack Smith got his business records
that's what I read from this
Donald Trump knows he's committed crime
Donald Trump knows what crimes he's
committed right he knows what [__]
what [__] transactions and what he
sold in uh in exchange
for that money or whatever payments he's
received or how he received it
he knows
he's well aware he's the one who did it
that's why he's in the situation that
he's in
and that's why he's terrified that Jack
Smith has the evidence of him receiving
payments for whatever it is he sold
whatever it is rather it's documents
rather it's who knows
but I think uh Espionage is not out of
the question here and that's what Donald
Trump is terrified of also by the way on
this letter at the top of the letterhead
this [__] bonehead posted this on
true social
and it's clear that his attorneys had no
clue that this that they that they had
no idea that he was going to put this
out in public
which they should have known better they
should have [__] known better that
this guy wasn't gonna post this [__] on
the internet
and the and the the best evidence I have
which is the best evidence of why they
didn't believe he was going to post this
on the Internet is because the attorney
who is the writing the writing attorney
on this his [__] cell phone number is
at the top on the header and yes when
Gabe Sanchez comes on today if we get
him on in about 15 minutes
we're gonna try to call this
[__]
I why I I just want to ask him a
question why can't I mean hey I want to
ask the question
I want to ask the question did you or
did Donald Trump write this letter who
wrote this that's the question I want to
know it's one that's the only question I
want to know it's a legitimate question
that the media should be asking don't
you think
TK says calm live on air what the [__]
do you think we're gonna do my guess is
my guess is is that this number is
already disconnected
I that's my guess there's no way there's
no way this number is still connected
that [__] went and changed his
number last night as soon as this
[__] thing dropped and everyone
noticed that the attorney's mobile phone
number was on this letterhead
he probably they probably locked the
line up to be quite honest
like you probably couldn't even get
through at that point so I doubt I doubt
the number is still active
we'll see some are saying that it went
straight to the mailbox
probably right just turn that
[__] off and he's hoping he'll
get his number back someday the people
will stop calling him but isn't it funny
isn't it funny how isn't it funny
how this attorney wrote this letter not
dreaming that Donald Trump would post
his [__] on the internet because he put
his [__] mobile phone number on it
he's like yeah sure I'll [__] write
it Jesus Christ if you just shut the
[__] up because you know that's the
conversation right
Trump is calling him just [__] just
badgering this guy to beg Garland to
drop the investigation and the guy's
like look man it's not gonna happen
that's not how it works that's not how
this [__] works
and Donald Trump's like look I'm above
the law okay and Merrick garden needs to
do what I say there's a two-tier justice
system in this country and I want my
tear to protect me because that's the
real thing that's what that's what this
letter is really saying folks that's
what this letter is really saying
that yes this is the two this is the
two-tier system all the [__]
moglodytes were bitching about when he
was indicted in New York
this is the two-tier justice system and
Donald Trump is terrified and pissed
that it's not going to protect him
anymore
I mean just ask yourself ask yourself do
you or anyone else you know
if you were being investigated and
possibly indicted on federal charges
would you be able to demand a meeting
from the Attorney General of the United
States
let me let me tell you a little story
and I know some of you might be shocked
but I've been I've been federally
indicted before
I the thought the thought
the thought
of me demanding a meeting with the
attorney general in the United States
never entered my mind ever
are you [__] kidding me
why in the [__] do does Maga does Maga
think
why do you really think
that they're talking out outside of what
they know that is a two-tier justice
system of course there's a two-tier
justice system
why do you think we're in the position
that we're in with Donald Trump
why do you think he's so terrified he's
terrified he's absolutely terrified that
his
tier of justice is not going to protect
him anymore
think about it
they're correct yes they are correct
there is a two-tier justice system in
this country absolutely
and we should not let that two-tier
justice system protect Donald Trump or
people like Donald Trump ever again it's
enough of the [__] it's enough of it
oh man the question's coming in right
now
[Music]
Aaron everybody loses their mind to chat
I don't know [__] go to patreon and
we'll we'll talk about it on ask me
anything maybe it'll do an ask me
anything tomorrow and then you guys can
ask me anything about it you know what
I'm talking about
I've talked about it in patreon before
this isn't news
I just haven't said it that way before
[Laughter]
oh my God but yes this is an indication
this is a total indication that there is
a two-tier justice system this is the
two-tier justice system that the
megalodites are talking about
and it's not going to protect people
like Donald Trump anymore
that's it
that's it someone uh Maria says on
YouTube I stand with Tony 100 yeah
absolutely why wouldn't you
why wouldn't you
laughs
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy that's gonna it's
gonna heat up the uh We've gained
audience members since I said that maybe
I should say that [__] more often I mean
I'm not scared of it it's the truth
it's what happened okay I'm gonna show
you um speaking of Q Anon holy [__] have
you heard of this guy Eli crane I never
heard of this guy until yesterday
this guy is a weirdo have you seen this
have you have you seen this
oh man Q Anon is a hell of a drug that's
what I said about this clip watch this
clip of um representative crane here
doesn't he this looks like a horror
movie right
come on man look at this [__]
let's listen to his line of questioning
here this is weird [__] Miss Murphy does
it concern you some of the revelations
that have been coming out of the
oversight committee about the millions
of dollars that have been paid to the
Biden family recently I'm not aware of
money being paid to the Biden family oh
you're she's like I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about man
now this person works for the FBI
that's right she's like I don't know
what the [__] you're talking about let's
let's see what let's see how many more
lines and Q and on conspiracy theories
Eli crane can throw at this this witness
you're not aware of that at all no sir
that's interesting you're that you work
for the FBI right
yes sir I do but I would respectfully
refer you to the investigators over that
case I'm sure we can get you a brief on
that that is not a case that that I
handle yeah well I don't need a brief on
that ma'am to know
that there are nation states that have
paid millions of dollars to the Biden
family
and that's one of the reasons that we're
having this hearing that's one of the
reasons that Americans are so concerned
that they see Chinese spy balloons
flying over the U.S for an entire week
oh my God so somehow
somehow this [__] bonus
thinks that Chinese spine balloons have
to do
with payments that were made and
disclosed on the treasury website to
members of the Biden family this is
weird [__] [__] man
I'm telling you
Q Anon is a hell of a drug I honestly
you know to some degree I wish I would
have bought into this stuff right like
you just make anything up imagine
imagine a life where you could just make
up whatever the [__] you wanted to
justify any kind of weird idea you had
think about it just anything
if you think it right and you want to
believe it but it's not true you just
make up some crazy ass story and that
crazy ass story is now true oh my God
and not only that you could run for
Congress and then go question a [__]
FBI agent
in a [__] hearing an official hearing
on the official record
imagine Jesus Christ this is [__]
this is crazy
let's keep going with the [__]
delusion uh let's see what else the ends
to puke up
that's why they're so concerned that
they see these Chinese police stations
being set up here and they're wondering
how could this go on this doesn't do
what
what the [__] did he just say
Chinese police stations
I I do not have I don't know about you I
just have a police station in my town
and let me tell you something it's
really not safe around there because it
is a bunch of [__] fascist cops
especially for people of color lgbtq
people people who are anti-anti police
right it's really unsafe for them around
there but Chinese police stations
want them what the [__] what is this
what the [__] okay let's keep going
doesn't make any sense
and yet the son of the president of the
United States is involved and entangled
for many years now in multiple business
deals that the president claims he knows
nothing about
and you ma'am you sit here before the
homeland security committee our job
that's right you heard that right this
guy is on the homeland security
committee now here's what he's saying
here's what he's saying and listen to me
good that it is a national security
threat
that the son of the president United
States before he came the president may
or may not have had transactions
business dealing in China now think
about this think about this real clear
Donald Trump while he was President
United States had Chinese bank accounts
had bank accounts in China now I'm not
saying that it's the same thing
but I'm just saying Eli
you should come with the same
[__] energy
as you have with Hunter Biden and his
fake ass laptop
to Donald Trump and his Chinese bank
accounts okay you should have the same
[__] energy you [__] weirdo let's
keep going it gets he gets stranger I
know that's hard to believe but let's do
it job is to protect the Homeland and
you act as if you don't know anything
about it
if you understand why the American
people are concerned ma'am
she's just like what the [__] are you
talking about man I don't I is there a
real question here that's really what I
would if I was her I'd been like is
there a real question that you got are
you just are you just asking rhetorical
[__] to try to spend your conspiracy
theories because if you had a real
question Maureen I came here to answer
your [__] question so if you would go
ahead and do your [__] job and ask me
a real [__] question instead of this
rhetorical [__] cubanon [__] a
lot of people are talking about the
Chinese police stations in the chat now
I know what he's talking about
but he's acting as if our government is
allowing it they're not allowing it
they're not they're not allowing it
they're rating them they're anyways
let's continue let's see what our answer
is to his non-question
yes or no I understand why American
people should be concerned about the
threat from the Chinese Communist party
yeah damn did you see that did you see
that
that that's how you toss us back in this
motherfucker's face now again I would go
a step further and say look if you got a
legitimate question I'm willing to stay
here and answer all the legitimate
questions that you have but until you
really have a legitimate question I
don't know what you're trying to ask me
you're saying all kinds of weird ass
[__] that has no basis in fact that I
can distinguish
and really until you put together a
sentence that I can understand and then
you put a question mark at the end of it
so I can answer a question then then
maybe maybe we should move on or I can
just go do my job since you're not gonna
do yours
um
maybe that sounds should work
do you see any connections with what I
talked about when I was talking about
Elite capture you see the dots at all no
sir you don't connect the dots no
because you're full of [__] man you're
full of [__] [__] this is an FBI
agent
she she can do full briefings
for this [__] on certain
subjects full [__] security briefings
for for Mr Crane who is on the homeland
security committee that's why she's
there to testify my guess is I don't
know this for sure but my guess is she
testified in public and she testified in
private and she probably gave full
security briefings to these
[__] including Elon crane if he
[__] wanted one
but he doesn't bother to know that and
he doesn't bother to care
because his goal is to look like a weird
[__] Nazi questioning someone with
all kinds of weird ass [__] and not
asking a real question do you see the do
you see the connections of the things
I'm trying to say do you do you smell
what I'm stepping in what the [__] come
on man get serious this is why this is
why they always make fools of themselves
is because they're not serious about
policy they're not serious about
Homeland Security and they don't have
serious staffs
do you think Eline crane could ever
attract a career staffer in Washington
you think this weirdo
asking the non-questions that he's
asking could get someone who's a
professional Snapper in Washington to
[__] think oh yeah that'd be a good
idea I'll go work for this guy that'll
look great on my resume no no and let me
tell you something
that is how it works
regardless if you like it or you hate it
regardless of of that it shouldn't be
that way there are career staffers not
just Republicans but Democrats and some
of them cross over all the time
because they know government
they know how our House of
Representatives works or the Senate
there's professional Senate staffers
there's professional House of
Representative staffers and the reason
why
is because they know how it operates
they know how our government works they
know what the components are they know
what the gears are they know how the
levers that's what it is
and the reason why Mr Crane is having
such a problem
seeming like a total [__] weirdo when
he's questioning a professional witness
who could give him a full briefing on
anything that she knows about
in our national security having to do
with the FBI and Homeland Security
he goes on this stupid [__] clown
show tirade
because he's a [__]
and not only is he a [__] he has no one
there to say that's really stupid you
should not ask her those questions those
aren't real questions
telling you
telling you if he had a real staffer an
actual real staffer the real staffer
would have a [__] law degree would
have studied the House of
Representatives probably would have
worked for four five six maybe a dozen
other staffs
that person would be his chief of staff
and that Chief of Staff would make sure
all the other staff members run
everything that every single [__]
question that this congressperson is
going to ask through them first before
the congressman asks it in the [__]
hearing
and that Chief of Staff if they were
serious and they knew what the [__] they
were doing they would have said you're
not saying any of this stuff
this [__] you're saying is all nonsense
it makes no sense you have no no form of
a question whatsoever and everyone is
now Dumber having listened to what you
just said
may God have mercy on your soul
I award you no points and may God have
mercy on you that's the [__] clip
that it reminds me of right listen it
gets worse I know you don't think it can
but here it goes
so your job is to protect the American
people
I just read you what Elite capture is
the summary the definition of the lead
capture
everybody knows in this town what's
going on everybody knows what's coming
out of these committee hearings right
now yeah it's all [__] we know it's
all [__] because you guys are just
spending lines and gaslighting Americans
because you you are trying to protect
your deity who is a [__] crook and a
[__] criminal and you're trying to
project his crimes on to someone else
his political enemy who is Joe Biden who
he's going to be running against in the
general election next year we all know
it
and if you don't know it then you're
you're a dumbass but that's what's
happening
and it's pretty sad
coming from somebody who as a young man
wanted to be a part of your organization
oh thank God thank God Mr Eline cranier
never could rise to the level to be part
of an organization like the FBI for
[__] crying out loud thank you very
much it's just too bad that some dumb
[__] in his district decided
it'd be a good idea for him to go
question those people as a member of
Congress [__] me
oh I just gotta show you the stupidity
and the weirdness it's such an awkward
Exchange
and the reason why is because these
Republicans are [__] weirdos they're
[__] weirdos do you want to see okay
let me show you something
um this Chantelle Brown of Ohio this is
this morning uh in the gas stove hearing
that's right the Republicans this
morning are holding holding an entire
hearing on gas stoves
next week it'll be rainbows at Target
they're gonna be throwing a [__]
meeting on rainbows Target it's a threat
to our country you want me to show you
what it [__] looks like when someone
has a professional staff
in the United States House of
Representatives do you want to see what
it looks like to be a serious
[__] when the opposite side of
the aisle is doing unserious things
in a [__] hearing you want to see you
want to see here it is watch what she is
doing making sure that gas stoves are
less expensive to operate and produce
fewer toxins and health stat uh health
hazards it is my hope that my Republican
colleagues will redirect their focus to
the well-being of American people rather
than whether than politicizing kitchen
appliances because you know what they
are Banning abortions you know what they
are Banning books you know what they
want ban assault weapons but we are
sitting up here talking about a ban on
gas stoves but oxy energy is doing
making sure there you go there's how you
do it there's how you do it that's how
you prepare a [__] monologue
makes sense points point point point not
just a bunch of [__] nonsense that
only people on [__] eight Chan will
understand
stupid [__] what do you get
what what do you want from me I I don't
get the I don't get the [__] make I
don't make these Republicans say this
stupid [__]
I just [__] show it to you when it
happens
that's that's all I do is I just show it
to you speaking of the target thing
here's here's I want to show you this
video and this is the video you should
be uh sharing around possibly
um now the first part of this video is
this [__] bigot here
this [__] weirdo going around Target
talking about the clothes that they got
for sale in Target
and how it's gonna indoctrinate your
children or some stupid [__] now wait
for the end wait for the end wait for
the receipts because the receipt's at
the end watch this we're at Target right
now and there's a lot of controversy
going on about all of the pride stuff
that's coming out with kids clothes and
things like that so we're gonna go to
the kids section and we're actually
going to see if they're putting weird
creepy uncomfy stuff on children's
clothing okay there's no controversy on
the clothes that they're putting out
it's you guys that are that are upset
no one else is upset it's like a handful
of [__] that are going in and
terrorizing the lgbtq community in this
country
and it just so happens that Target has
some clothes that they would like to
sell to lgbtq people and their allies
and if you don't like it fine stay the
[__] out of the store and don't buy it
it's not complicated you're converting
the controversy no one else thinks it's
controversial only a handful of dumb
sons of [__] let's continue
okay this is the child section okay did
you see that she held up two onesies two
onesies okay did you catch that now
watch what she does literally the kids
section I'm next to a literal onesie yep
that says whatever the hell that means
we have glad you came out and I'm so
happy that you're queer those are not in
the challenge section by the way those
are cards in the kids nope nope
okay here's here's where here's where
she gets sideways here here's where she
starts lying in her video here you go
I'm sorry
sorry toddler don't belong in the same
sentence so I found an extra small
swimsuit in the child section says light
binding effect on it
and then the bottoms in the kids section
keep in mind
say
tuck friendly Construction
they're giving it to your kids if that
doesn't give you a reason to boycott
Target I don't know what does but okay
it's a [__] line and we're gonna show
the receipt they're gonna show the
receipts here in the video watch this
this shit's getting out of hand they're
targeting children whether you like it
or not and it's now they're not we'll
actually do something about it
and guess what that [__] won't just be
in Target it'll be in every store yeah
it should be and everybody can pick up
an article of clothing and bring it into
a different apartment in the store and
say look this is a kid's clothing but
the websites don't lie since you hit the
whole piece of clothing we can just see
that the stitching is just of a neon
rainbow color
kind of exactly like this one yeah
adult bikini swim top
it also features a light binding effect
to help express your gender identity so
I think we can all agree that this is
the article of clothing that you are
saying is a kid's bathing suit here are
the bottles Pride adult bikini swim
bottom adult you can go on Target's
website and look at everything they have
available for children and for babies
for clothing and none of the clothing
for the kids are anything like that
article clothing that you claim to be
for children
I get that you're doubling down because
the crowd that you are catering to
typically does not do their own research
they hear something and they [__] run
with it they never fact check it
themselves but you should be [__]
embarrassed if you have to lie to try
and make a point you never have
and there you go there you go so when
they get in the comments and they're
talking about this [__] and again again
I I'm I'm expressing frustration about
left too that you people are [__]
targeting Target which is weird to say
but it's not Target it's not Target it's
[__] boxes like this it's terrorists
like this who are trying to stoke fear
online to get people to act in a certain
way by lying to them Target's not lying
Target's not lying
they're having their [__] displays
knocked down dismantled people are being
harassed in their [__] stores by
people like domestic terrorists like
Ethan Schmidt who's a Kerry Lake
supporter who's not surprising that
domestic terrorists with some more
support carry Lake
so yeah
direct your energy in the appropriate
Direction like against people like this
and people who get in the comments who
lie it's [__] lie all right um let's
uh
I'm done with the target thing I really
am I'm [__] sick of that [__]
Target [__] in the Bud Light [__] I'm
sick of it listen go not drink whatever
beer you want shop whatever store you
want I don't give a [__] quit your
bitching if you don't like Target don't
[__] go in there if you don't like
Bud Light order something else you dumb
[__] Jesus Christ speaking of
terrorist did you know there's a
terrorist in the United States Senate
I'm not [__] you I mean there's
several of them
here's one of them Rick Scott of Florida
of course it's not surprising that Rick
Scott
and that Republican senator from Florida
is a domestic terrorist and he's calling
for hostile actions towards the lgbtq
and socialist here it is
look at this Washington D.C today
Senator Rick Scott issued a formal
travel advisee for all socialists
visiting the State of Florida and again
don't get it twisted when they say
socialist they mean they mean left and
allies of the left
they mean anyone who who wants Freedom
who wants Liberty for everyone and all
people who don't want to ban books you
want to ban assault weapons so that
children are safe in schools
that's what he's talking about from
visiting the State of Florida the travel
advisory comes in direct response to the
Biden Administration attempt to erase
capitalism what the [__] are you talking
about Rick Scott
your goddamn Governors trying to get rid
of a private business one of the biggest
private businesses one of the biggest
Employers in your state
a race capitalism get the [__] out of
here he goes on to say in the system
that has brought prosperity to Florida
for the in the entire United States you
mean like I don't know Disney
ah you [__] ass wipe
he goes on to say in the next paragraph
This is where it gets heated this is
where the stochastic terrorism comes in
listen the formal travel notice States
quote Florida is openly hostile
towards socialists Communists and those
that enable them before traveling the
floor to please understand that the
state of Florida's values and
marginalizes and contributions
challenges faced by socialists and
others who work in the buying
Administration
he's a terrorist
all right
we all know that thanks Rick Scott okay
here is um here's more on the uh [__]
if you want to see more of the [__]
more of the rake stepping here's another
um rake stepping this is Russell fry
he's a congressman from South Carolina
not surprising
um he's gonna talk about here uh all the
evidence that he doesn't have and
doesn't exist against Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden let's listen are we getting
closer to the point where we can make
the statement that Vice President Biden
took money while in office are we
getting closer to being able to say that
I think every day you know we're
continuing to subpoena bank records
connect the dots on the Biden family
scheme what what influence they were
peddling overseas and then coming back
and you see these Bank deposits from
Shell companies overseas after the
bidens return home uh I think every day
is a new revelation about what is going
on and what has been going on for far
too long with this family I want to
bring up the elections are we getting
closer to them so that would be a no no
there's no evidence and they don't have
it and they're not gonna have it because
it doesn't exist
Jesus Christ
that's a no this is not going to go
anywhere there is no criminal
investigation that's what they're mad
about okay here's Merrick's tweet I
brought it up earlier so I want to show
it to you
uh Merrick's tweet here on here on
Twitter Matt Walsh tweeted and earlier
this morning he tweeted the goal to make
quote Pride toxic for Brands if they
decide to shove this garbage in our face
it's not your face man what are you
talking about it's not in your face
change the channel don't go to Stores
stay indoors Matt stay in your house
turn the lights off don't turn on the
internet
it's what you should do
if you decide to shove this garbage
interface we should know that they'll
pay the price it wouldn't be worth
whatever they think they'll gain first
Bud Light now on target what are you
talking about
what the [__] are you talking about Bud
Light Bud Light didn't go anywhere
there's still Bud Light there'll
continue to be Bud Light there's still
Target they're going to continue they're
probably going to put these displays up
as soon as you [__] boneheads forget
about this stuff
he says our campaign is making progress
let's keep going yeah
Merrick says wow
Ed how quickly he dropped the pretense
it was only about trans kids and now
it's about any
queer representation because that's the
[__] truth that's the [__] truth
they're Nazis this is how it works I
keep telling you people this that it was
never it was never about trans kids it's
about taking away your consent your
consent regardless if your trade kids
are are trans or part of the lgbtq
community it's designed to take away
your consent because in States like Iowa
they're pushing back labor laws
while they're forcing kids not to be in
school because of school choice
it's all [__]
all of it it's all a slow step to
fascism
that's all it is every [__] bit of it
and if you don't fight now if you don't
fight now
then they'll come for you they will
first it was the Socialist then it was
the trans kids now it's the lgbtq
community next well its first was women
if you want to know the God's honest
truth
who next who next well I'll tell you who
next Amanda Gorman
Amanda Gorman's poem that she spoke
at the inauguration of Joe Biden
in 2021 January 2021 just days after the
January 6 Insurrection just days after
the president United States Donald Trump
at the time tried to overthrow our
government and commit a coup to be the
dictator and the king of the United
States Amanda Gorman stood up and
delivered one of the most inspiring
speeches one of the
inspiring poems that has ever been spoke
at an inauguration ever
and Florida is now Banning it
because they're afraid of people like
Amanda Gorman and this country going and
looking like Amanda Gorman which it
should let's listen we will not be
turned around or interrupted by
intimidation because we know our
inaction and an Ursa will be the
inheritance of the next generation Our
blenders become their burdens but one
thing is certain
if we merge Mercy with mites into mites
with rights the love becomes our Legacy
and there you go that's the words they
are terrified of that's the words they
are scared of that is what they think is
indoctrination you can absolutely 100
percent go [__] yourself
a hundred percent if you think that
those are words of indoctrination you
people are [__] brain dead you're
[__] delusional and this all in
Florida State of Florida is gonna ban
this thing everywhere because a one
parent doesn't like Amanda Gorman
because she's black and because she's a
woman and because a black woman has
influence and a black woman is educated
and a black woman can write poetry and a
black woman can influence America to be
inspired
by her they're offended well [__] you
and apparently this one parent is tied
to the proud boys hmm I wonder what it
is I wonder what it is [__] out of here
with this [__]
everyone yelling and screaming this
isn't white supremacy of course it is
of course it is what do you think this
school choice [__] is
what do you think this [__] against
trans people is
what do you think what do you think this
scourge of of calling for terrorism
against the lgbtq community is it's
white supremacy
being
perpetrated by white Christian
nationalist it's fascism you
[__]
listen up and listen good
yeah boy oh boy oh boy oh boy let's see
what else do we have oh
I got another great example another
great example
of when you what happens when you elect
serious people to Congress
and those serious people attract serious
staff
and those serious people seriously
dismantle dumb [__]
in Congressional hearings
I tell you what I hope Daniel Goldman
never leaves Congress I know there's
going to be a lot of people like oh make
him make him the president or make him a
senator but whatever
I actually don't think I I want I want
Daniel Goldman to be a congressman for
the rest of his [__] life until they
have to wheel him in in a wheelchair
like they did Feinstein that's right
that's what I want
he is so God damn good at this
he is such a serious person and he knows
exactly how the process works
and he absolutely wants these fascist
Liars up and dunks them in the trash
every [__] day every single day he
does it nothing to do and let me show
you give you an example here again this
is an example of a serious person who is
serious about being a member of Congress
who is serious about the work of a
member of Congress and who has serious
staff members watch as he tears the
Durham report to [__] shreds first
let's talk about the Durham Port uh oh
I'll make it real short for you Miss
Murphy
um the Durham reports seem to fail to
consider the fact that the original tip
that set off the Opera Crossfire
hurricane investigation
was that Russia would be disseminating
hacked emails about related that would
help Donald Trump
and lo and behold at the end of July
that's exactly what happened so the
Durham report
focused solely on what was internally
within the intelligence files of the FBI
and did not mention the obvious
corroboration that the tip turned out to
be true second the Durham report
said that an investigation was justified
to be opened it should have just been a
preliminary investigation as opposed to
a full investigation third
the Durham report talks all about the
steel dossier which had nothing to do
with the origination of the Russia
investigation and had nothing to do with
the Mueller investigation it was not
relied on that investigation of course
led to I believe six individuals
connected to the Trump campaign who were
convicted
whereas the Durham report the Durham
investigation uh had one guilty plea by
someone who was referred from the office
of Inspector General and two acquittals
on pretty pathetic charges so let's get
our facts straight about the Durham
report second
I want to address what my colleague from
Arizona was saying about the FBI
whistleblowers I was actually in that
hearing last week he was not okay so
he's talking about e-line crane here
look at this look at this guy does he he
looks even more weird when he's not
leaning into the microphone am I wrong
am I wrong about that
this guy looks like a listen a lot of
people thought that that Ted Cruz was
the Zodiac Killer
like a lot of people some people believe
that [__] that Ted Cruz is a murder
lizard and he's the Zodiac Killer
but look at this guy
I don't know maybe we were wrong about
Ted Cruz maybe Ted Cruz is just a
[__] in that piece of garbage and he
just happens to look like Eline crane
who is the Zodiac Killer
not saying he is
saying
pick out some
people [__]
in a lineup that looked like the Zodiac
Killer
Eline crane may be one of them that you
would pick out I don't know let's
continue let's find out maybe maybe
Daniel Goodman gets to the bottom of
that
so what I can tell you about those
individuals is separate and apart from
whether they are whistleblowers or not
they were deemed by the FBI to be
National Security risks
yeah oh man hmm it's surreal convenient
we talked about this before Jim Jordan's
little whistleblowers that they had
they're not whistleblowers they're paid
operatives they're paid by Donald Trump
and cash Patel
prove me wrong [__] you they're paid
operatives to lie
and they were fired from the FBI and
removed from the FBI because they suck
and it sucks to suck tough [__]
and because you can't get a real
whistleblower
okay one other video I want to show I
was hoping to get Gabe Sanchez on here
for this
I know yesterday was Taco Tuesday
and did you guys have tacos did you did
you drink margaritas with your tacos did
you did you drink Margaritas anybody
raise your hand in the chat if you had
tacos and you had margaritas
with your tacos yesterday it was Taco
Tuesday so maybe maybe some no one had
Margaritas yesterday Jesus [__]
Christ
some people said yes
they had tacos but no marks
come on some people say they had nachos
nachos say nachos
uh all that taco stuff and gay beer it
sounds like you're drinking Bud Light
uh let's see what else we get
um and indeed had tacos okay who had
Margaritas no one just tacos
Taco Bell Roderick oh man Roderick you
really piss off Gabe Sanchez with that
statement
Chris says he had a Big Mac no idea why
slim jim tacos no you didn't that's
disgusting trust me I know
um tacos but no booze
all right I don't know why didn't you
guys no one had Margaritas at all are
you [__] me come on man
come on
Uncle fatty says slim jim squeeze cheese
and Jagermeister I highly doubt that
sounds like a bad idea I still um and
and says pomegranate margaritas and
and let me ask you how many Margaritas
did you have and how many how many
Margaritas did you have
I'm not baiting anyone I promise
ah this next uh just tequila shots
Midas DW says just tequila shots someone
says Margaritas give him heartburn and
oh Laureen says I had marks and Tacos on
Sunday uh tequila
I'm just
I'm just trying to figure out who in the
chat had Margaritas that's all I'm
trying to do because this next video is
gonna it's gonna knock your socks off
you Margarita drinkers
um so there's that lady who was um
preaching abstinence down at uh LSU
Louisiana State University
she was outside she had a a PA system
right she's talking into a PA system and
she was talking about abstinence to
these students at LSU and the cat and
the crowd started together
she was gathering up a crowd I mean
these these kids were really excited
about her talking about amsterdance damn
it Gabe says he's going to be on here in
just a minute I want to wait now God
damn
let's see I just
[Laughter]
I'm trying to get him on here so I can
do this I want to see his reaction
to this lady talking about abstinence
and margaritas it's a thing and some of
you may have already seen this video
but it's um
some people are saying abstinence at LSU
right exactly any college really right
any college really abstinence but no
that's why I think this lady went to LSU
because there probably isn't a lot of
abstinence
um at LSU there's a lot of people
[__] at the college there I'm sure
these are young adults they're horny
they they're ready to you know
experience life do drugs drink
margaritas and possibly experience
sexual activity it's a possibility it's
likely right
but anyways this lady goes to preach
abstinence because that's the thing that
you do is when people are horny right
when you got a lot of horny young adults
all gathered up in one area what you do
is tell them they can't do that thing
you don't try to teach them I don't know
like
what it actually means to have a sexual
relationship then educate them about the
safety of having sex why it's important
to practice safety why it's important to
practice consent why it's important that
you have these conversations and educate
these children I mean you know what
they're at LSU they're young adults
they're just coming into adulthood they
should probably be educated and learn
about these things I don't know maybe
I'm crazy maybe I'm off my [__]
rocker
yeah
to do that sort of thing at a college
educate people
but this person goes down and she's like
ow abstinence that's the only thing that
matters that's the only thing that
matters
well she got a a weird surprise here
when she started to preach her style of
abstinence
here it is listen to what she says about
margaritas
and what happens when women drink
Margaritas very important very important
that this Kook is talking about when
women drink Margarita she doesn't
mention men but listen to what she says
and listen how the students are excited
I mean and it ain't just the guys I mean
the guys are really excited about these
prospects but the women seem to be
excited too listen to what
she's preaching here
buy her spread her legs
[Applause]
pound right on your penis
she will grab your penis and put it in
her mouth
foreign
so it's not going exactly the way she
wants right
am I wrong I don't think she really gets
that these people are very excited about
what she's saying about Margaritas now
is this the truth absolutely not I don't
believe that if a woman drinks a
margarita any of this stuff is true I
don't think these people in this crowd
think it's true it's hilarious that this
lady is saying this
as she's trying to keep these people
from not having sex
I don't know why she's encouraging them
to drink Margaritas to have more sex
it's the wrong way to go about it it's
the wrong perspective of Education when
it comes to sexual activity I think you
know it gets hairy in the in the realm
of safety and consent
I listen as the crowd starts to count
this gets hilarious
[Applause]
he will grab your penis ran that right
up here
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second
now I have a problem on this right off
the bat okay here's the problem that I
have
is that she went from Three Margaritas
right now this is why I don't believe
that this is satire some are asking if
it's out there I don't actually believe
this is a zetter I believe this woman
doesn't know what the [__] she's talking
about that's what I believe
and the reason why is because if you go
from Three Margaritas right if you're
using her logic this is not my logic I
don't believe this is true if you go to
Three Margaritas and the woman the woman
who's drinking The margaritas is gonna
stick your penis in her mouth right okay
three and then you go to one more she
goes directly to sticking in her anus
what
I don't I don't think I I'm not sure
about you
I'm not sure about you but I don't know
that that is gonna I don't think that's
the thing right that's not the jump that
you make from three to four I'm just
saying I'm just saying what do you want
me again I don't I don't I didn't force
this woman to go down and preach to
these kids abstinence and be saying
things that excites them that gets them
to not do the thing that she's trying to
get them to do right I don't know
so I don't think this is satire because
she went straight from put it in your
mouth to put it in your ass what
what how does that I don't think that's
the I don't think that's the correct
number well let's listen to what she
says about five and watch them count
this is hilarious
oh my God
all right
and The Crowd Goes Wild for pegging The
Crowd Goes absolutely [__] wild for
pegging now for those of you out there
who do not know what pegging it I had to
look this up okay I absolutely had to do
my research on this no way do I know
what this means
so she went from this is I'm telling you
this is her logic right now this makes
sense coming from this woman that
obviously why I'm saying it's not satire
this woman has no [__] clue what
she's talking about she went from three
sticking in your mouth forward to
sticking in your anus to five she's
gonna put a strap on
and stick it in your anus that's the
route now she's thinking she here's what
she's thinking is that one Margarita bad
nope the crowd's like yes two margaritas
bad nope the crab's like we want more
Three Margaritas whoa the crowd is going
wild let's go for four maybe they'll
hate what I have in store for them for
four Margaritas the crab bubble that
five Margaritas she was sure that the
gentleman the young boys in the crowd
would not want to hear after five
Margaritas what would happen to them if
the lady that they were with was gonna
have five margaritas
she was completely dead wrong every
single one of them sheared now why is
this important Henry says you looked it
up Tony I I
totally looked it up
I totally did not know what that is
anyways the point is this point is this
get your mind out of the gutter the
point is this is that you gotta remember
where they said this is that LSU this is
in Louisiana
the LSU University and this lady is
preaching abstinence now this is the
[__] brain dead thinking that the
Christian right does in this country
this is the brain dead thinking that
mogulodites have the same [__] now this
is a funny video it's hilarious it's
[__] hilarious no matter how you
shake it
um Gabe Sanchez how many Margaritas did
you have last night we're trying to make
sure we know exactly did you want one
two three four or five Margaritas six
whoa what the [__] is six if five is
pegging what the [__] I know you watched
this video because I said yeah yeah
what like six Margaritas yeah it means
that there are neighbors that come in
and give an extra hand so it's like an
orgy kind of but like you're a swing
involved I'm just gonna swing there's
some cables right oh okay yeah yeah but
it it's not necessarily that everyone is
having sex it's that there are just
extra hands oh random hands that come in
I got you it's just like dude what else
am I gonna do Republicans are gonna ban
this [__] like that and uh if I don't do
it now when will I right right well you
know the CR the audience was asking if
this was satire and at first I thought
it was but then when you kind of Do The
Tick Tock through the number of
margaritas you're like how does she go
from three that she'll stick in in her
mouth to four she'll stick it in her
pain like that's not that's not the
appropriate Direction no it doesn't it
doesn't make a lot of sense on how they
or how she gets to that but at the same
time
I mean I I texted you I was like don't
threaten me with a good time
oh hell yeah well you know what's funny
is I I told the audience that I had to
look up pegging oh and you know what
that was
no absolutely not no clue no experience
whatsoever in the pegging area
all right no no no we're not doing the
[__] Whispering the audience is
already in a [__] dizzy as it is the
craziest part about this and what this
has to do with anything other than it's
a great laugh is that this is the same
stupid [__] that they do with everything
right this is the same rake stepping
that they do because this is a huge rake
step that this because she's like maybe
I got these people on board for
abstinence and like she's like maybe the
woo and
Wows are like for me and supporting
meanwhile every like because I think
it's at LSU is where she's doing it so
you've got like all the [__] frat
dudes and sorority people and randomly
from classes that are totally all of
them are totally gonna go [__] sometime
later that night and at the same time
you hear all of these noise like oh yeah
oh man oh [__] they're like one two
three like and then everyone on campus
is like what's going on and they all
head there right and it's just this
because it kind of makes me think like
you know she's like uh here I'm gonna
warn you here's a PSA I'm gonna warn you
of what happens when you do multiple
drinks of uh or multiple shots of
tequila right or multiple margaritas and
it kind of has that like Streisand
effect reference like oh [__] that's how
that works okay we're going back to the
frat house we're gonna check this [__]
out right right exactly like again I I
understand that you know the abstinence
thing is really bone yeah anyways you
can't you can't force you can't Fork
especially two consenting adults to have
abstinence before they're married this
is really ridiculous stuff just like
just like to expect that your little
bathroom bills and your states are going
to keep people who look like men out of
women's restrooms you're actually
causing that problem that you say you're
trying to solve your white is just as
bad I don't know this argument I know
it's uh no I'm not saying I'm not saying
that I don't want the margarita argument
yeah I'm not saying that there shouldn't
be Margaritas out there that you know
after you have five of them you don't
want to Peg the dude you're with I'm not
saying that that's fine whatever you
want to do if you're consenting adults
hey have at it have five margaritas and
Peg each other all night long I don't
give a [__] that's your that's your deal
that's your deal but the problem is is
that they think this is a style of
Education right this is the actual
indoctrination now these boneheads who
are sitting there and they're horny as
hell and they definitely want to drink
Margaritas don't give a [__] if she's
fine I wouldn't be surprised if they're
if every bar on LSU's campus right down
like their bar row where everyone's like
Margarita yeah let's go like margaritas
it's margarita week now right the idea
that they're like oh [__] everyone's all
hyped up on Margaritas we're now going
to have Margaritas Margarita is special
like you know I don't know what her name
is like we're calling it Margarita Mandy
or like Margarita you know Margaret or
like whatever her name is I have no idea
but I I honestly like I think it would
be totally uh poor business to not
capitalize on that moment
and then just be like we're doing one
two three four five Margaritas like you
know something like that I don't know
you know what you know what you could do
if you're a bar owner you could you
could sell a special yeah five
margaritas and a strap-on five margarita
actually actually maybe maybe you do
call it the margarita Margaret because
the nickname for Margaret is Peg or
Peggy I am yeah
yeah that makes sense maybe that's how
she got to five Margaritas was pegging
because Margaret nicknamed Peggy hmm
I don't know I have no idea honestly I
think what she was trying to do is like
hey you don't want her to stick it in
your her mouth and they're like yeah we
do and she's like whoa wait a second
okay so I'm gonna go one further you
there's no way these boys here are gonna
want to stick it in her you know and
they're like yeah we do and she's like
okay I'll do you one better
[__] there's no way you're
gonna want her to stick it in urine
they're like yeah we do you have no idea
she had no clue that the internet exists
yeah she has no clue that PornHub exists
and she has no idea that people of of
both you know of whatever sexuality is
like yeah you know what I get off on
random things and one of those things is
being pegged and there's nothing wrong
with that right as long as it's
consensual I'm okay with it exactly
whatever you want to do and you know
that's the I I just want to bring this
up that's zero days zero days that we've
talked about porn so it's hard to do
when you do a show that is centered
around what's trending on the internet
there's always going to be something or
someone that brings up something
pornographic or sexual oh my god well it
happens especially when you have videos
I don't know all I'm saying is I'm a big
fan of margaritas and I was a big fan of
Margaret Margaritas even before I saw
this video and now
all right
Peggy Margarita me that's what I say I'm
just saying I mean it makes sense right
bring it up the Peggy that's what you
would call it too at your restaurant or
your bar right can I get a Peggy yeah
buy Margaritas buy margaritas and a
strap-on the pig the pig good God week
is it do you get a brand new one or like
is it a you use it then you have to give
it back they clean it wash it they get
and then they get someone else sanitary
I think I think wash it right you know
put in the put in the dishwasher I guess
I guess they re-wash the pictures and
the glasses so why not re-wash the you
know everyone we're just we're just
communal you know socialistic uh
Tendencies You Know sexual sexual
socialism we'll call it oh my god did
you see Kevin speak speaking speaking of
a fake dildos did you see Kevin McCarthy
this morning
blending blaming that he can't get the
debt ceiling raised with his caucus on
the president United States he's like oh
didn't he complain it's his fault I
can't do my job wait didn't he say
yesterday or maybe it was two days ago
he talked about how uh how accomplished
the 118th 118th Congress was he's like
yeah right exactly what have they done
nothing absolutely nothing they've
passed re-elected him they've passed uh
they've passed the bills in the house
which have no chance of passing in the
Senate and definitely even if they pass
in the Senate would not even get the
signature of of Biden at his desk
but they're like oh we secured the
Border no what you guys are still
bitching about the border right they're
like oh we got rid of this woke stuff
there was never a problem to begin with
right they're like oh we got rid of this
and we did this and it's like no you
didn't you you killed 80 well you tried
to kill 87 000 IRS jobs uh you try to do
this you try to do that you know
unsuccessfully of course you know might
I add but at the end of the day it's
like
what has he done so the question is like
uh what have they done totally
legitimate question not a goddamn thing
here's the thing is
it's starting to become a reality to
Kevin McCarthy and the Republicans in
the house that he's a [__] well that
was kind of obvious that that they are
going to be blamed at the debt ceiling
isn't raised right right this is why
Mitch McConnell has stayed out of this
fight the entire time okay because what
is what is known but is unknown to most
and I haven't really talked about it
because I prefer that the president 14th
this thing that's what I prefer is
because I believe my personal opinion is
that the debt ceiling is
unconstitutional it's a stupid fight
it's a stupid [__] thing that they do
and they use it to [__] Americans uh out
of what is ours the GDP that is ours
they use it to [__] us out of it they
use it to [__] keep taxes low on the
rich and cut the [__] benefits of the
rest of Americans and again taking away
their GDP but here's the thing that no
one's really talked about until now and
I'm going to bring it up today is that
Mitch McConnell does have a dog in this
fight and the reason why is because
Mitch McConnell is not going to let
um the [__] debt ceiling go
um unraised and and destroy the American
economy because Mitch McConnell is
[__] violent as much of a demon as
that guy is he understands one thing is
that the Republicans can't be fully
full-on blamed for the economy crashing
and Mitch McConnell definitely
understands that if Kevin McCarthy does
not get his caucus in order and does not
raise the debt ceiling and come to come
to grips with the president is only
going to sign a certain amount of bills
and the president is the one who signs
that
that it could they could go past the
debt limit and we could be [__] Mitch
McConnell is not going to let that
happen yeah now here's what it seems is
going to happen
um I'm trying to look for the um is
there a video of the statement today of
Mitch McConnell
um I don't know if there's video but
Mitch McConnell is basically signaling
that hey I'm waiting for Kevin McCarthy
yeah I'm waiting for there was a
statement I think it was La end of last
week where they were outside the White
House they had a meeting well Mitch
McConnell was like it's your Facebook
yeah he was like basically like uh
that's uh look we got our [__] figured
out
um you want to figure that one out like
this is a this is a Kevin McCarthy
problem right here's here's here's Mitch
McConnell saying it's a Kevin McCarthy
problem listen
and the president and the speaker are
the keys to the deal
I'm prepared to try to deliver as much
of my conference as I can
for whatever the speaker and the
president can agree to so there it is
he's basically putting um all of it on
McCarthy not my problem not my problem
now it is Mitch McConnell's problem
because it is his party and his party is
going to be blamed and he knows that
they are they are definitely going to
lose the house in 2024 and one of the
reasons is their extreme views on
abortion they're extreme views on trans
people they're extreme views on [__]
lies about Hunter by any family hold on
you're telling me that none of these uh
none of these investigations and
policies and ideologies are something
that resonates with majority of
Americans not not even close now here's
fair enough that's I won't even
challenge you now Mitch McConnell knows
this Mitch McConnell also knows that he
he would like to make sure that he has
as many people in his conference in the
Senate as he possibly can and this is
all going to be down ballot races
because he knows that Trump's going to
be president but Mitch McConnell is not
going to be the savior fear of the debt
ceiling unless he absolutely has to be
because he doesn't want to be blamed by
Republicans for being the one who raised
the debt ceiling right you see the con
the [__] back and forth here but
here's what I see happening it's going
to come down to the wire this morning
Kevin McCarthy announced that there was
no deal that the deals have stopped it's
paused and the reason why folks is
because the president United States has
said no you're not going to do 22
percent Top Line spending you're not
going to affect Americans because you
won't do your job and you won't raise
the debt limit even though the [__]
thing's unconstitutional the
administration Janet yelling and
everyone else has signaled that this
thing is [__] unconstitutional we
will 14th it if we have to it is a it is
it is the last minute move but we will
do it if we have to we will consider
this to demon unconstitutional and get
rid of this debate altogether that is
the other thing that Mitch McConnell
does not want to have is this debate
being taken off the table because Mitch
McConnell knows one thing that there is
if they they can raise the debt ceiling
for one year they will be able to have
this fight next year they will be able
to try their best their damnedest to
blame this on Democrats it won't work it
never works because Democrats are the
ones who want to raise the debt ceiling
they actually don't want the debt
ceiling because it's dumb as [__] it's
dumb as [__] to say we're going to
appropriate all these funds and then
later you have to reapprove them because
some stupid arbitrary [__] but also
you've got you know Kevin McCarthy and
the Republican Party who have again you
know uh Joe Biden got them all on the
record National Television he said
Republicans want to take away Medicare
and Social Security they want to cut
those things and they said boo no and he
goes okay great you guys agree you want
to save it sounds great to me I got you
on the [__] record now I got you
saying that you disagree with the
statement that everyone else said about
you guys which was true and is true is
that you guys want to cut government
spending for these programs
and the fact that now that he has him on
the record and he's like look man
tell me what you guys got I see no
proposals as to what your budget is no
one's seen it everyone's talked about it
Kevin McCarthy said oh no we're not
going to cut anything I'm not going to
cut anything then just days ago or so we
learned oh yeah they're going to cut a
significant amount and I wonder where
those things are going to come from yeah
well it's Top Line spinning everything
basically okay Top Line spending is this
folks if you want to put it in a simple
nutshell all budgetary measures all of
them excluding a few like military
Top Line spending is 22 percent cuts
across the board okay across the board
the VA Medicare Social Security snap all
those programs that provide federal
funds in the most read of red states by
the way yep more people receive more
money in red States than they [__]
spend
dollar for dollar
which is who represents who represents
red States more than these [__]
Republicans in the Republican caucus
these Top Line spending cuts are going
to affect their constituents the most
that's the design I've been telling you
the design is to squeeze their
constituents to make them think Biden's
economy is bad
and it's [__] but that's what
they're trying to do now Mitch McConnell
knows this here but here's Kevin
McCarthy this morning uh acen points out
that he kept using this one line
throughout the entire speech so it's not
my fault that the Democrats today have
become so extreme so far to the
Socialist Wing that they are now opposed
to work requirements what the [__] is he
talking about it's not my fault extreme
you mean just passing a clean debt
ceiling is Extreme because they did it
three times under Trump right give me a
[__] break and again this this is
Kevin McCarthy clearly signaling this
morning because he said this over and
over it's not my fault it's Democrats
fault he's clearly signaling that he
knows he's going to be blamed his caucus
is going is that guy yeah he's trying
well what he's trying to do is he's
trying to protect himself for later
which obviously won't work but by saying
like it's not my fault it's not my fault
he's like I put it on the record it's
not my fault guys I said it was my fault
just because you say it's not your fault
it doesn't mean that it's not your
[__] fault man if your party if
you're supposed supposed to be the
leader of your party if you have the
majority in the house and you can't get
your [__] people in order and you
can't get an agreement on the books as
to what's going to happen because if
Biden's already said look I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna compromise on this I'm not
gonna make these Cuts right you guys
said you wouldn't make these Cuts so
guess what we're not going to make these
[__] cuts
so the idea that Kevin McCarthy is not
like ah guys it's not my fault I swear
guys it's not my fault like uh you know
I mean dude the guy could have [__]
you know caught red-handed be like it's
not my fault right it's like the joke
that we made the other day with with the
[__] shag he was like it wasn't me
it's honestly that right like Kevin
McCarthy will be caught red-handed
[__] with the debt ceiling
negotiations
and it is it is you are the Speaker of
the House his legacy right now if there
was a if if we had just a few more
districts
um about six or seven to be exact we'd
have a king Jeffries and NADA Dunn had a
debt ceiling past it had been on the
president's desk and he'd have done
signed it oh yes Democrats Democrats
aren't and really honestly this is kind
of what pisses me off Democrats aren't
against the debt ceiling
in Washington because yes Washington
wants to have these fights they want to
have these negotiations they want to
have this drama and this [__] back
and forth us the American people do not
and that's why my hope is is that it
goes all the way down to the wire in the
president 14s this thing even if they
get it passed but here's what I see
happening and this is the signal from
this morning as Kevin McCarthy is
whining that it's not his fault
um and he's begging the Senate because
he said several times I listen to most
the press conference he said where's the
Senate Bill where's the Senate Bill
where's the Senate Bill well this is
what is going to happen more than likely
folks it's going to come down I'm sure
Schumer and McConnell already have a
deal they already have the votes for a
clean debt ceiling raise and they will
pass it they will force McCarthy to
bring it to the floor it will receive
the majority of democratic votes it will
receive a handful Republican votes it
will go to the president's desk and be
signed at the very last moment as the
market starts to have its downturn and
they start to freak the [__] out now my
my my my preference is that the
president United States 14s this thing
as soon as he signs that bill in the law
he says look I'm signing this to raise
it so we don't have the market crash
right we don't have the economy crash
for the American people but I'm going to
14th this thing because I want it
challenged in court I think that's what
he should do I don't think we should
have this fight anymore and that's the
reason why I believe Mitch McConnell
at the end of the day is going to be the
one that swoops in and [__] does the
deal with Schumer pushes it to the house
gets gets whips enough Republican house
votes forces Kevin McCarthy to get this
to the floor he will probably not be the
speaker after this fight because he's a
[__] idiot yeah and he [__]
doesn't know how to be the speaker of
the house he never should have been the
speaker of the house yeah I don't know
who over there could have been but it
definitely shouldn't have been him he
doesn't know how to be the speaker of
the house it is clear today that that is
the case here's more of the [__] uh
let me show you where he's talking about
concessions [__] your concessions man
[__] your there is no concession you're
talking about the American economy for
average Americans because you want to
have a fight about funds that have
already been appropriated these aren't
Cuts in the future he's talking about
Cuts in the future because the money
they spent in the past
you [__] boneheads so do a budget
raise the debt ceiling pay your debt and
do a [__] budget you pieces of [__]
let's listen let's do that that's all
we're asking we're being reasonable no
you're not
probably in the house definitely in the
Senate you're the Democrat in the white
house why not offer a single concession
Beyond saying we're not going to default
we've offered a lot of concessions the
cap on the spending is a Democrat idea
no it's not the work requirement was a
Democrat no it's not it's not idea
the time I can't help it if the
Democrats have become so extreme and now
it's a party of Bernie Sanders then the
party where Joe Biden was elected Joe
Biden I don't understand why why do they
think that still resonates yeah I know I
have no idea why they think why they
think there's this huge fervor for
Bernie out there I mean yeah I mean
maybe there's there's a small group of
people that still like Bernie Sanders
well where where is Bernie Sanders in
the public Discord
I I have no idea the only time I've
recently seen Bernie Sanders is when he
had when he spoke with uh fetterman
right but that was what that was the
latest yeah but the only people Bernie
Sanders speaks to and the only people
that are really listening to him are his
supporters not America America listen
let me let me let me give you guys a
clue let me give you guys a [__] clue
and I I don't know if you remember
the 2020 race and I'm talking about the
primary the Democrat primary Joe Biden
was broke in Iowa he didn't have any
[__] money the media is like he's
done he's done he's done he's done he'll
never make it he ain't got enough money
Bernie Sanders looks like the
independent who is not a Democrat is
going to win this race Joe Biden went to
South Carolina got Jim clyburn's
endorsement he clobbered
clobbered Bernie Sanders in South
Carolina and continued to clobber him
for one reason and one reason only
because Bernie Sanders kept saying the
words Medicare for all and even even in
the Democratic party folks even in the
Democratic party of those primary voters
who vote in those States for the
Democratic party said no no the
Democratic party is not the party of
Bernie Sanders it never was it never was
going to be and if you think it is you
are not paying attention I had to tweet
at someone on tyt I forget her name and
I'm not gonna just I'll bring her tweet
up she asked this morning why tell me a
reason why Marianne Williamson isn't the
greatest candidate and well because she
can't beat Joe Biden yeah you [__]
buffoons stop stop with your [__]
stop with your lies stop with it Marin
Williamson cannot be the [__] nominee
because she cannot beat an incumbent
president that's not a thing and if you
think it's a thing just go back in
history and look and if you think that
we're everything's gonna change because
you don't like Biden you are a stupid
[__] stop stop with the nonsense
stop with it it only encourages empowers
[__] like this and like we
we've talked about it with Dr Rachel
bidikoffer is like the the analogy would
be scaling a mountain right like let's
say you're climbing Mount Everest right
and and the idea that why would you
start from scratch and go back all the
way to the bottom versus if you're
halfway up and you have all of this
success so far right everything that Joe
Biden did at the end of or in the middle
of you know spring and summer of last
year right multiple bills passed
multiple accomplishments made multiple
things that were that were done that
were for the betterment of of you know
the uh citizens or I'm Americans uh
constituents
um but again it's that analogy of if
you're scaling Mount Everest let's say
and you're halfway up right
why would you go all the way back down
to the bottom and reset with somebody
that hasn't done that now I'm not saying
that
like I'm not saying that candidates
aren't like worthy of running but I am
saying that if you're running against
someone an incumbent president and an
incumbent president who has these things
even and it doesn't matter if you're not
accomplished the Democratic primary
process allows the incumbent president
to have two terms so does the Republican
primary right that's how it works
Sheldon here says Bernie's very vocal
yes I I agree and someone else said uh
Bernie uh Bernie shows a lot of support
for unions absolutely um um
no one's bashing on Bernie here I'm not
saying Bernie is bad I'm not saying
Bernie is bad but
right
right Bernie is not the reflection of
the left's ideology it's not and I'm not
I I actually believe if you want to know
the the the full truth about Bernie
Sanders and how I feel about Bernie
Sanders folks I've been watching Bernie
Sanders since 2004. you got it 2000
almost [__] 20 years I've been
watching Bernie Sanders okay I'm in pain
attention to politics for a long [__]
time
and Bernie Sanders is a crucial part of
the less [__] vocal
um position and what Bernie Sanders does
the best is he's the independent senator
from Vermont
Bernie Sanders gets to say whatever the
[__] Bernie Sanders wants you got it and
because of his run in 2016 and in 2020
he is he has coalesced a lot of power in
his support which is which is great on
the Democratic left and the reason why
is because Bernie Sanders and his allies
can pull the Democrats to the left okay
that's how ideology works and until you
really figure out how ideology Works
you're not going to understand how our
two-party system works you have to
understand that Bernie Sanders is a
crucial part of the left he's a crucial
part of pulling the ideology of the
country to the left without Snapback
because that's what the right does so
[__] stupidly is they use their
ideology they use their power they use
their influence to pull it so far to the
right and Institute policies
without thinking what the consequences
of those policies are and the right just
lets them do it the Republicans just let
them do it and there's total Snapback
and we see that happening now and it's
going to continue to happen as long as
they keep giving this their their surge
of fascism it's going to keep happening
now back to Bernie Kevin McCarthy is 100
wrong the Democratic party has never
been the party of Bernie Sanders and the
reason why is because Bernie Sanders is
not a Democrat that's the [__] cold
hard facts and if you don't know that
then you don't know politics and if you
don't know that Bernie Sanders is always
an independent never he never he never
was a Democrat the only time he changes
a party affiliation was to give his
delegates from Vermont to to Hillary
Clinton he switches delegates from
Vermont to Joe Biden and he switched
back to being an independent and if you
don't know that you're a bonehead and if
you don't know how ideology works and
how it's separate from our two-party
system those are two [__] different
things then you've got and you have to
[__] educate yourself well the other
thing too that I want to add to that is
the idea that like you know as powerful
you know world leader as the president
is there are you know they walk into the
Oval Office with their hands tied in
many ways and when you're a
representative and when you're a senator
and you're actually in the legislator
and you're you know writing these bills
and passing them and proposing them you
actually do have a lot more influence
and a lot more control
than let's say the president does right
like a president doesn't have the same
amount of control that he did once
before or she did once before
and so
having Bernie in the Senate and still
being independent like he has a lot more
control than you'd think he would have
or a lot more influence you think he
would have and and especially in terms
of whipping certain votes right
so
um that's why some people when you know
I think when when they've been asked
like would you ever run for president
while they might be a great candidate
and make a great President right you
also have to remember that then they say
well you know what I have a lot more
flexibility I have a lot more freedom in
my in my uh in my job where I'm at right
now than I would if I was President
right
um and that's and that's something to
remember uh as well when when somebody
says oh you know Bernie Bernie should
run Bernie or whatever you know it's
like he's also been able to accomplish a
lot just by himself in the Senate
um and so to your point too as well as
like Kevin McCarthy he's trying to what
he's doing is he's trying to place blame
on any person he can he's like well
Biden won't do this and people are like
dude you have to come to the table with
the [__] man he's made it very clear and
he's been very vocal and he's been
caught and he's called you out you have
no proposals you have not come with a
budget you have not been specific you
said oh we're gonna make these cuts and
we're not gonna cut this and we're not
gonna cut that but it's like have you
actually put it on paper have you
actually submitted a budget to say this
is exactly what we're proposing because
right now all it seems like these are
just like some ideas that are lofted up
nothing's concrete you haven't decided
on anything because you yourself Kevin
McCarthy can't figure out the end game
here
and you think that your only way forward
is to blame people so that you can
protect your potential run again in 2024
right or whatever the next re-election
is for him
well and I I agree with you that Kevin
McCarthy is using this as some sort of
weird thing that he I mean he'll
probably blame Hakeem Jeffries at some
point right like
all right he already he already invoked
and King Jeffrey's name but a king
Jeffries is actually the minority leader
in the house Bernie Sanders is a senator
right is a senator okay and Bernie
Sanders was in the public discourse and
again I know a lot of people out there
that follow Bernie think Bernie's in a
public discourse trust me when I say
this he's not he's not in the public
discourse he's not on the minds of any
average Americans on on a day-to-day
basis he's not he's not he's very
effective he's very effective in the
Senate he's very effective for the left
he's a very effective
um uh a member of the democratic caucus
like Roderick pointed out he's very
effective in that manner he has a lot he
has get garnished a lot of power in the
senate for an independent who isn't
actually a member of the party that he
caucuses with right it's very important
that you understand that that's very
important but this isn't about this is
not about Bernie and that's what Kevin
McCarthy is trying to make it about
because he's desperate to not be blamed
for this so he wants anyone and everyone
to take blame and I mean
spaghetti on the wall he's like we'll do
the kitchen sink approach like I'll
throw everything at it right and maybe
something will stick somebody will grab
onto something of the narrative and
continue to blame these people but at
the end of the day it's Kev McCarthy
Kevin McCarthy's to blame they've had
adequate more than adequate time they
knew this deadline was coming right they
knew what was going to happen absolutely
they knew the side effects what would
happen if they did not pass
this bill right did not you know uh uh
pass anything to protect us from from
defaulting or from from collapsing on on
the debt ceiling and so they've had
plenty of time right plenty even before
they came in the the [__] 180th
Congress knew what was going to happen
and they knew the deadline they were up
against and what did they do they spent
all this time immediately the first
thing they proposed was we're gonna
we're gonna totally repeal this 87 000
IRS job it doesn't exist doesn't exist
then they were like we're gonna get rid
of these woke gas stoves right and these
woke dishwashers and you know what we're
gonna do we're not actually gonna Focus
yeah we're not gonna focus on the gun
issues and the gun violence
Twitter files yes
and we're gonna go back and we're gonna
go to the border and we're gonna talk
and how do we how do we protect you you
know according to Marjorie Taylor green
the other day when she got [__]
schooled on the capital steps by uh
Jamal Bowman he was like protect the kid
she's like yeah the Border he's like
what the [__] does that have to do with
anything well because what are you
talking about she went on a hell of a
drug now I I don't want to go without
pointing out this tweet from Jessica
Burbank I I invoke this tweet so I want
to make sure now again I want to be
clear I like Jessica I follow Jessica
I've retweeted Jessica I agree with some
of the [__] she says this is the most
bone-ended thing I think she's ever said
on Twitter and I'm willing to point it
out and really honestly if Jessica
wanted to come on the show I have a
challenger and she could challenge me on
it she's not gonna have a fun time doing
it because I understand how Democratic
primaries work she clearly does not I
wish she did now this may seem um you
know sort of
a punch at tyt it just so happens that
Jessica does content for tyt some of it
I've liked I think me and her agree a
lot on Elon and elon's [__] he's an
idiot he's a silver spoon idiot but I do
not agree with her on this and this is
really boneheaded really boneheaded she
says no one has given me a reason why
Marianne Williamson is who she's talking
about Marian Williams isn't the best
candidate in the 2024 field okay she
goes on and says it's never I think
she's unlikable it's always I don't
think other people will like her I don't
know what that means when are you going
to stop shooting yourself on the foot
with this mentality I said here's
Jessica I gave you the reason this is
the reason there's only one reason
there's only one that matters there's
only one because she can't beat an
incumbent president in the Democratic
party it doesn't matter if it's Joe
Biden
Barack Obama it doesn't matter if it's
Bill Clinton or Jimmy Carter it doesn't
matter go back and I don't care if
you're a Democrat or Republican in this
instance it's a Democratic primary not a
Republican primary of an incumbent but
you can not in our two-party system and
I
if it changed it changed and I would
disagree I'm like yeah we can have other
you are not going to have an incumbent
president of either party
have a challenger and be able to have
that challenge or become the candidate
in 2024. uh Jay says she's not electable
and she's not electable and the reason
why is because she can't win the
primaries Joe bot listen to me folks Joe
Biden is going to go to the convention
next summer in Chicago he's going to
walk on the stage he's going to give a
speech they're going to vote with their
delegates for him well before that
they're going to vote with their
delegates and the super delegates are
going to hand him a nomination it
doesn't matter what Marion wins does it
doesn't matter what Robert Kennedy RFK
Jr does it doesn't matter who gets in
the race it does not matter Joe Biden is
going to win on the first ballot at the
Democratic National Convention next
summer in Chicago that's how it's going
to work that's how he's going to be the
Democratic nominee he's going to be on
the ticket and that's just how it works
if you don't like it fine go get your
candidate for 2028. that's the beauty of
our system here in this country is a
president only gets two terms now now
that's it that's all they get they don't
get any more than two terms so when Joe
Biden's turns up Marianne Williamson
maybe she could be the best candidate in
2028 right but not in 2024 it's just not
about it it's also you know if you had a
candidate or if you had a you know an
incumbent president who was demo you
know from the Democratic party who is
right now let's say Joe Biden let's say
Joe Biden didn't do [__] right he didn't
accomplish anything he you know bucked
to a lot of the things that Republicans
wanted to do like he he didn't he didn't
do anything right he didn't put his foot
down he didn't hold he was you know not
a great International like world leader
he wasn't a great domestic world like
leader
when you have a you're like okay great
you know what we're gonna either you're
not running again or we're gonna primary
you for a good reason
but if you've got someone who's been
able to accomplish a lot in in a less
than a two year period and you've got
someone who knows how to work with other
sides with people on the other side of
the aisle right
and you've got someone who has a good
relationship with other International
leaders these are not things that you
want to say you know what let's just
start over guys let's just like throw
that [__] out right
unless it was a complete failure then
sure like maybe we address this whole
like should be primary should we bring
someone else in that we think is more
you know more competent more successful
more uh more of a leader what have you
but to the Marianne Williamson thing
like it's just it doesn't make a lot of
sense like they're not even if she was a
great candidate you're not gonna find
the type of unity now in in backing the
other person and the other reason the
other reason I think it's so important
is because you've got Ron DeSantis who's
about to announce unfuck oh that's gonna
be fantastic I wish we had so much more
time to talk about this but we'll talk
about it tomorrow yeah he's gonna
announce I mean well here's the thing
one is he already announced he's running
for president he announced he was
running for president by announcing he
was going to announce for president yeah
right so I mean that's not official
because he hasn't done on Twitter spaces
yet but whatever the [__] it's going to
be a cringe-worthy [__] flop of an
announcement because everyone knew what
was going to happen and they're like oh
what are you guys going to talk about
policies that you've been put in place
in Florida you're getting sued by
[__] uh Hamburger Mary's you're
getting sued on multiple different
fronts for other things you're Banning
books Banning pronouns Banning people
from going into bathrooms you're not
successful
your anti-American pro-fascist policies
are actually going to hurt the country
they've already cost your state 2 000
jobs and a billion dollar contract with
[__] Disney
you're going to tell me that this guy is
the best shot you got but you know what
I'm not gonna stop you I'm not gonna
stop that's right you're gonna run
against this other guy who's another
[__] failure and he's gonna [__] and
moan him he's doing it this morning he
was like Rhonda sanctimonious in Florida
and this and that link speaking of that
before we go before we go because we're
way over time here
um and and there's a lot of comments in
the in the chat about Whitmer uh excuse
me about Williamson and some about
Whitmer and I think Whitmer would wax uh
Williamson's ass in a primary Williamson
will never win a primary 2024 or 2028
she's a lunatic she's a lunatic she just
says whatever the [__] she has to say to
get on tyt yeah hey did you hear what I
just said she says whatever she has to
say to get on tyt that's what it is and
really honestly Jessica if you're if you
see this because I told her her tweet
sucks and I told her it was featured on
today's show I'm not scared of that
Jessica if you hear me you can come on
here and I'll I'll we'll talk about it
you're I mean it's not gonna go well
when when you get [__] hammered with
what the truth is but come come on I I'm
willing to have a conversation with you
about it but here's the thing about this
Ron DeSantis thing and the Trump thing
okay
do you think do you [__] think that
Trump tweets the minute Rhonda Santos
opens his mouth oh absolutely oh my God
I hope he [__] no wait no on Twitter
not on true social oh on Twitter man
just dude he could [__] tweet I'm
gonna have a space right now and open a
space and just [__] honestly you know
what [__] this is uh
we are giving advice free advice like
normal yeah if you're out there
listening uh Trump campaign because I
know you guys Liz Harrington Donald
Trump Jesus Don Jr whoever's listening
whoever is this let's do it call this
this is a bat signal a free [__] bad
signal for you all you gotta do is start
your own Twitter space at the same time
oh my God or maybe a minute before or
maybe yeah
just dueling Twitter space do you know
what I actually think this is this is
Elon trying to get Trump on Twitter
that's what I actually think possible
he did say he was going to vote for
DeSantis in 2024. WoW but again I think
this is all this is all the [__] kind
of troll Trump and to get him on Twitter
and there's no better sign no better
opportunity than right now when Rhonda
Sanchez I mean like as soon as Ron
DeSantis fucking's like I'm gonna run
for prison 2020 just Donald Trump starts
tweeting I'm gonna have a live right now
Boom the live goes up just [__]
everyone dumps out of Rhonda Santos's
room and goes in the truck oh my God you
I can't tell you how much of a dumpster
fire the Republican primary is going to
be and that would kick it off just that
would be [__] beautiful so Donald
Donny man I know I know you think I hate
you which I [__] do demonly I [__]
hate your guts man all [__] 400
pounds of them okay but I'm telling you
tonight
for the for the sake of the intersection
of WrestleMania in real life please for
the love of God get on Twitter and start
a space the minute Ron meatball pudding
fingers DeSantis opens his mouth start a
Twitter space and do that please and you
know what you should do on Twitter while
you're over there you should follow us
on Twitter and Tony Michael's fine no
but also before we go uh I hear people
in the comments and I also know that we
talked about yesterday I'm gonna call
Trump's attorney oh live on oh we forgot
to do that oh yeah we got to do that
okay it's a Arlington Virginia number so
let me just uh it's gonna go it's it's
probably gonna go uh John Rowley you
wish my mobile phone please leave a
message and I will call you asking the
question I can thanks very much what
question
I'll call it again did he like did he
write the letter to Trump
his mailbox isn't full yet no it's not
wow that's his cell phone number should
I call the office number no call his
cell phone leave me message all right
all right just tell him your Gabe
Sanchez with what was that and you're
wondering if uh
I'm not gonna say who I am
why not you [__] the mailbox is full
and can I oh
ah there you go we [__] tried I told
you they would tell you before you got
the voicemail oh sorry this voicemail or
this voicemail box is full no no you
know what's funny is last night um me
and you were talking about it in text
you like we're gonna call them all live
on air I'm like that's cool but by
tomorrow that [__] that number
is gonna be shut down well I called it I
called it last night and the voicemail
box was still open oh so you could have
left a message then damn well and there
it is there it is folks make sure to
follow us because we do stupid [__] like
that on this show make sure to subscribe
here on YouTube to the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific live live
live and then you can download the
edited version on Apple Spotify and
Google as soon as I get it posted up and
then they put it up there and it's 3.99
on your favorite podcast directory it
doesn't cost you a single nickel also
you can watch for free Gabe's engines on
Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account just go to at the Tony Michaels
at Johnny Michaels we air there live
every single weekday just as we do on
Twitch you can follow us on Twitch it's
[__] free free free over on Twitch to
follow us also thank you to all the
subscribers who have linked their Prime
account to their Twitch account and gave
us that one free subscription you get
with your Prime account don't forget if
you go to the Tony michaels.com that's
the Tony michaels.com there's a link
there showing you how to
a link your Amazon account and your
Twitch account and give us that one free
subscription and we get a couple bucks
from Amazon it's a free way for you to
give us money if you have an Amazon
Prime account really cool way for us to
have money also don't forget don't
forget why you're at the Tony
michaels.com click the patreon button
check out what's happening on my patreon
but also visit what was thatshow.com
[Music]
it's about uh Ron DeSantis making his
cringe-worthy announcement on Twitter so
perfect subscribe check it out people on
the patreon it's already live so go go
go awesome so go to what was that
show.com or go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out the patreon there also
why you're on patreon again check out my
page as well we appreciate all the
support not just the support monetarily
but when you guys are here every [__]
weekday two full hours noon Eastern 11
Central nine Pacific the entire time
we gotta kick it tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
's meal Barn head ass Beacon